[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
Fall hier bei Tatort Deutschland und
dieser Fall ist ein Albtraum ich bin
Mirko kimir und ich bin stefanetzeband
hallo Stefan was ist im Bereich Mord und
Totschlag dein schlimmster Albtraum also
ich habe natürlich keine Lust ermordet
zu werden das mal vorweg aber richtig
Schiss hätte ich tatsächlich davor
irgendwie im Zorn selber zum Mörder zu
werden oder unschuldig ins Gefängnis zu
kommen na okay so ähnlich würde ich das
glaube ich für mich auch sagen und um
letzteres geht es ja heute bei uns um
den sogenannten badewannenmord
über diesen Titel müssen wir uns am Ende
sicherlich noch mal unterhalten aber
fangen wir am Anfang
an
am Abend des 28 Oktober 2008
bildreporterin Lena Zander Liselotte K
war 87 Jahre alt als sie im Oktober 2008
tot in ihrer Badewanne gefunden wird man
könnte im ersten Moment meinen dass sei
nichts Ungewöhnliches doch der
Gerichtsmediziner schaut sich den Tatort
an und stellt fest ihm kommt das nicht
so vor als sei es ein Unfall gewesen
also wird ein Verdächtiger gesucht und
dieser wird gefunden in Form von f
gendinski gendinski ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt Hausmeister in rotterchegern
am Tegernsee er kennt das Ehepaar K
schon ein paar Jahre als 2007 der Mann
von Liselotte K stirbt übernimmt er
Aufgaben im Haushalt unterstützt die
alte Dame bei Einkäufen und fährt sie
auch regelmäßig zum Arzt so auch an dem
Tattag er holte sie aus dem Krankenhaus
ab brachte sie nach Hause und war somit
der letzte Mensch der lisalotte K lebend
sah es war die Mitarbeiterin eines
ambulanten Pflegedienstes die liseelotte
K auffand aber wie Lena eben schon
angerissen hat war auch Manfred
genditzki ganz erheblich damit
beschäftigt sich um die alte Frau zu
kümmern Hans holzeider von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung hat das sehr gut
zusammengefasst und zwar so
genditzki machte ihr morgens das
Frühstück kaufte für sie ein wusch ihre
Wäsche fuhr sie zum Arzt und zum Friseur
löste ihre Schecks bei der Bank ein und
war zu jeder Tag und Nachtzeit für Sie
verfügbar sie zahlte ihm 100 € im Monat
500 € zu Weihnachten gab auch mal ein
großzügiges trinkgelt oft kam auch
genditzkis Frau Maria mit dem kleinen
Daniel zum kaffeet Trinken Frau KL
liebte den Buben immer hatte sie ein
Stück Schokolade für ihn am Vormittag
des 28 Oktobers hatte genditzki
Liselotte K aus dem Krankenhaus abgeholt
wo sie einige Tage wegen einer schweren
Durchfallerkrankung gelegen hatte er
hatte ihr Kaffee gekocht und sich dann
von ihr abschiedet weil er seine Mutter
besuchen wollte die auch im Krankenhaus
lag und weiter genditki hat sagt er
zweimal versucht Kars Hausarzt anzurufen
um ihn über die Entlassung seiner
Patientin zu informieren aber gleich
wieder aufgelegt weil eben nur der
Anrufbeantworter dran war das war laut
anrufprotokollen um 14:57 Uhr dann sei
er zum edik in badwisi gefahren um noch
Einkäufe für VK zu erledigen auf dem Weg
dorthin habe er noch den Pflegedienst
angerufen dass Frau K jetzt wieder zu
Hause sei der Anruf wurde um 15:09 Uhr
registriert der kassenbom vom edik weiß
die Uhrzeit 15:30 Uhr aus zu all den
Details von diesem Tag will eigentlich
kein Mord passen und tatsächlich
Vergehen vier Monate bis die
Staatsanwaltschaft ein Mordmotiv und
einen Tatablauf konstruiert hat und
zuschlägt am 26 februar 2000 wird
Manfred genditzki wegen Mordes verhaftet
laut Anklage hat er Liselotte K in der
Badewanne aus Habgier ertränkt genditzki
habe Geld unterschlagen Frau K habe dies
entdeckt und ihn zur Rede gestellt
daraufhin sei er wütend geworden und
habe sie ertränkt um nicht angezeigt zu
werden mit dieser wilden Geschichte
erhibt die Staatsanwaltschaft München Z
ziemlich genau ein Jahr nach dem Tod der
alten Frau offiziell Anklage wegen
Mordes und unter
am 25 November beginnt dann der Prozess
vor dem
Landgericht nächste Wegmarke der 11 mai
2010 jetzt wird die habgierthorie im
Prozess soweit entkräftet dass der
Staatsanwalt im schlussploer ein neues
Tatmotiv
präsentiert und zwar einen Streit
zwischen Liselotte K und genditzki weil
der nicht wie von ihr gewünscht noch
einen Kaffee mit ihr trinken wollte sei
sie böse geworden im Zorn habe genditzki
sie dann in die Wanne gestoßen und
getötet absolut absurd und noch absurder
dass das Gericht ihn tatsächlich am 12
Mai 2010 wegen Mordes zu lebenslanger
Haft verurteilt hier ist die
Urteilsbegründung der Angeklagte war
Hausmeister in der Wohnanlage im
Landkreis Miesbach in der auch die
87-Jährige liseelottek wohnte der
Angeklagte war die Hauptbezugsperson der
Frau und kümmerte sich täglich um sie
Frau K war auf diese Unterstützung und
Hilfeleistungen des Angeklagten
angewiesen nach einem mehrtägigen
Krankenhausaufenthalt holte der
Angeklagte sie am
28.10.2008 aus dem Krankenhaus ab und
fuhr sie nach Hause in ihrer Wohnung kam
es zu einer streitigen
Auseinandersetzung in deren Verlauf der
Angeklagte Frau K mit einem stumpfen
Gegenstand zweimal von hinten auf den
Kopf schlug oder sie mit dem Kopf gegen
einen Gegenstand stieß aus Angst vor
weiteren Konsequenzen entschloss er sich
das vorangegangene Geschehen zu
verdecken indem er Frau K tötete und
dies als Unfall durch einen Sturz in die
Badewanne erscheinen ließ er verbrachte
Frau K in die Badewanne ließ Wasser
einlaufen und drückte ihren Kopf so
lange unter Wasser bis sie ertrunken war
dann verließ er die Wohnung die Leiche
der Frau K wurde am Abend von einer
Mitarbeiterin des Pflegedienstes
aufgefunden der Angeklagte war zur
Tatzeit weder alkoholisiert noch durch
sonstige psychiatrisch relevante
Umstände in seine einsichts und
Steuerungsfähigkeit
ausgeschlossen und Manfred genditzki
muss ins Gefängnis er brüllt niemanden
an er schwört keine Rache für ein
Fehlurteil er sagt einfach ich bin aber
unschuldig und fügt sich seinem
Schicksal vorläufig muss man betonen
denn aufgegeben hat kenditk nie das
zeigt sich an der Chronik des
juristischen tauziehs das nun beginnt 12
januar 2011 der Bundesgerichtshof hebt
den Schuldspruch aus
verfahrensrechtlichen Gründen auf und
verweist die Sache zurück an das
Landgericht München
I 17 Januar 2012 Manfried genditzki wird
erneut vom Landgericht München I zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt genditzki
legt Revision ein 5 september 2012 der
Bundesgerichtshof weist die Revision
ab zwischen zeitlich hat die Anwältin
Regina Rick den Fall übernommen sie
kämpft mit großem Eifer für eine
Wiederaufnahme des Verfahrens es hat
sich ein großer Unterstützerkreis
gebildet auf der Homepage
manfred-genditzki.or wird der Fall
dargestellt und für eine Petition
geworben
11.06.2019 der Antrag auf Zulassung der
Wiederaufnahme wird eingereicht darin
heißt es unter anderem nachdem ein
sturzgeschehen nicht mehr ausgeschloss
werden kann ist dem vom Gericht
angenommenen Geschehensablauf einer
Gewalttat die tatsächliche Grundlage
völlig entzogen ein vom Gericht
lediglich ins Blaue hinein vermuteter
Streit ist nicht geeignet den
Schuldspruch zu
stützen
1.12.2020 der Antrag auf Zulassung der
Wiederaufnahme wird vom Landgericht
München 1
abgelehnt
23.9.2021 der Antrag des Verurteilten
Manfred benogenditzki auf Wiederaufnahme
des abgeschlossenen Verfahrens wird für
zulässig
[Musik]
erklärt das war eine sehr verkürzte
Zusammenfassung aber tatsächlich hat
Anwältin Rick sich durchgesetzt der Fall
muss neu verhandelt werden wichtig dabei
war eine fachliche Untersuchung
bildreporterin Lena
Zander Stuttgarter Forscher haben sich
dann der Tat noch mal angenommen und
alles ganz genau untersucht sie haben
eine Simulation des Unfalls bzw des
Sturzes oder des Mordes das war zu dem
Zeitpunkt ja noch nicht klar
nachgestellt anhand der Blutergüsse die
bei Frau K gefunden wurden oder auch der
Lage in der sie aufgefunden wurde und
kam zu dem Ergebnis dass es sich beim
Tod von Liselotte K um einen Unfall
handeln muss das war der essentielle
Beweis für ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren das Gutachten
stammt vom Sachverständigen Schmidt
Professor für Biophysik und biorobotik
Schmidt ist Leiter des Zentrums für
Simulationstechnologie an der
Universität Stuttgart Verteidigerin Rick
hat ihn beauftragt nach mehr als 50
Simulationsläufen die er durchführte ist
es sehr wahrscheinlich dass Frau K nur
durch einen Sturz in die Badewanne in
die Endlage kam in der die Pflegerin sie
am 28 Oktober 2008 vorfand das linke
Bein über den Wannenrand hängend dazu
Pass seiner Auffassung nach die zwei
häatom an der Kopfschwarte der Frau K
und die Lage eines Pantoffels der unter
dem Waschbecken lag Anwältin Rick macht
der Justiz mit Verlaub Feuer unterm
Hintern ihre Argumentation geht wörtlich
in etwa
so laut damaliger Anklage soll die ganze
Tat innerhalb von nur 11 Minuten
abgelaufen sein in diesen 11 Minuten
soll genditzki sich entschlossen haben
Frau K zu ertränken er soll die alte
Dame die 74 K wog ins Badezimmer
verbracht Wasser eingelassen und sie bis
zum Eintritt des Todes unter Wasser
gedrückt haben was allein mindestens 5
Minuten gedauert hätte zudem hätte er ja
noch den Tatort präparieren also z.B den
Gehstock und die Pantoffeln im
Badezimmer positionieren müssen dann
hätte er immer noch innerhalb dieser 11
Minuten die Wohnung im ersten Stock
verlassen müssen um so dann in aller
Ruhe den Pflegedienst anzurufen und das
alles ohne Spuren zu hinterlassen ich w
wde sagen das schafft nicht mal ein
rutinierter
Auftragskiller es kommt wie es zurecht
alle erwarten Freispruch nach der
Wiederaufnahme
4912 Tage saß Manfred gendinski
unschuldig im Gefängnis als dann die
Wiederaufnahme vor Gericht stattfand war
wirklich alles voll bei der
Urteilsverkündung war jeder Platz
besetzt Journalisten Unterstützer saßen
dort im Raum und auch die Richterin war
sehr angefasst hat sich bei Herrn
gendinski entschuldigt als sie ihn
freigesprochen hat schließlich hat der
Hausmeister 13 Jahre unschuldig hinter
Gitter gesessen die Geburt seiner
zweiten Tochter z.B hat er nur in
uhurhaft erlebt Tibo Frasch von der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung schreibt
über diesen
Tag als der Angeklagte Manfred genditzki
im Saal 101 des Münchner
strafjustizzentrums tatsächlich
freigesprochen wird und zwar wegen
erwiesener Unschuld herrscht weder bei
ihm noch auf der Empore wo die Zuschauer
sitzen Jubelstimmung zu bitter waren die
vergangenen Jahre die ihm die Justiz
gestohlen hat genditzkis Familie ist da
und Unterstützer wie der ehemalige SPD
Landtagsabgeordnete Franz Schindler ohne
die er wohl gar nicht so weit gekommen
wäre die beiden Töchter liegen sich
still in den Armen die jüngere der
beiden sowie auch den ebenfalls
anwesenden Sohn gend nicht aufwachsen
sehen Richterin
elisabethl wendet sich direkt an gendit
mit Tränen in den Augen wir haben ihre
äerung
nachvert sie haben das in
bewundernwerter Art und Weise ertragen
sie sind aus tatsächlichen Gründen wegen
erwiesener Unschuld freizusprechen bei
den Ermittlungen wurde manches sehr
einseitig verarbeitet und zu Ihren
Lasten gewertet wir müssen feststellen
dass Kontrollmechanismen hier nicht
funktioniert haben es tut uns wirklich
aufrichtig leid dass Sie mitten aus
ihrem normalen Leben gerissen wurden es
war ihnen so nicht vergönnt ihre beiden
jüngeren Kinder aufwachsen zu sehen oder
zu Beerdigung ihrer Mutter zu gehen
Manfred genditzki sagt nach dem
Urteilsspruch vor zahlreichen
Reportern ja ich bin erleichtert dass
endlich mal die Wahrheit ans Licht
gekommen ist soeit geht's ganz gut aber
ich sag mal so im Grund zum jeln habe
ich nicht 14 Jahre sind weg also ich
werde jetzt keine freundenspringe
machen das letzte Wort in diesem Fall
hat bildreporterin Lena
Zander bemerkenswert ist auf jeden Fall
wie Manfred gendinski sich über 13 Jahre
Verhalten hat er war immer ruhig er war
immer besonnen hat immer seine Unschuld
beteuert und auch beim Freispruch
niemanden dafür verantwortlich gemacht
dass er so lange unschuldig im Gefängnis
gesessen hat was man auch nicht
vergessen darf ist er hatte einen
wahnsinnig tollen Unterstützerkreis
seine Familie hat immer an seine
Unschuld geglaubt es gab auch andere
Außenstehende die ihn unterstützt haben
es gab Onlinepetitionen und nicht
zuletzt auch seine Anwältin Frau Rick
die maßgeblich dazu beigetragen hat dass
Manfred gendinski jetzt ein freier Mann
ist eine parallele ist mir übrigens noch
aufgefallen die Anwältin Regina Rick die
ist uns schon begegnet ohne dass wir sie
genannt haben und zwar in der Episode
Rud rups Tod und das Fehlurteil das
findet ihr mit diesem Namen in unserem
Stream bei den Podcast Plattformen und
eins wollte ich auch noch aufheben der
badewannenmord ist so gesehen ja einfach
gar kein badewannenmord gewesen sondern
ein Badewannen Todesfall das war's für
heute wir haben diesen Fall erzählt mit
den Unterlagen aus der Bildredaktion
sowie mehreren sehr guten Artikeln aus
Süddeutscher Zeitung und Frankfurter
allgemeiner
zeitungtefanzeb Produktion durch schwarz
audio berlin vielen Dank fürs Zuhören
euer Mirko und euer
Stefan